Vivian is with us in Nebraska hi Vivian
how are you I'm good thank you take my
call sure how can I help okay
two years ago I bought a property that
had a house and an extra lot with the
hopes of building a house on the extra
lot which we are going to build next
year last year I discovered you and we
paid off everything except for this
piece of property and I've been saving
to build a house on this property with
cash but right now I have enough to pay
off that loan I didn't know if I should
continue paint saving to build cash the
house for cash or pay off this loan the
loan on the property correct okay so if
you pay how much is the loan on the
property nine thirty okay and how
expensive a home are you going to build
about 250 and there is a house on the
property right now those rented right
but it's a it's a separate lot that you
will build on okay now if you don't pay
it off and you use this money to build
the build a house you're going to have
to separate that lot from the current
loan the current loan has a lien on both
properties correct and you're going to
get that lot separated out because
they're not going to give you a
Construction recessed is to separate and
deeded Lots I know what do they have a
lien on both with the current loan oh
crap yeah you got to get that lot
released because that construction
lender is not going to take a second
mortgage position behind your current
mortgage so because of that mechanical
complication I'm probably going to go
ahead and pay it off with the money
you've got and then let your
construction loan I'm assuming you're
getting a construction loan the Builder
you're going to wait to save up and pay
cash the plan was just pay cash for the
house and I should have we sure we will
have enough saved up before we build the
house well if you do that you won't need
to do what I'm talking about then then
it's six and one-half dozen the other
isn't it that's right it wasn't sure
about yeah so I mean it really it
doesn't matter because they if you pay
off the current loan and then you end up
taking $130,000 loan on the
house that's exactly the same you put
yourself right back in the same place
right correct except you'd probably put
that new loan on only the lot with your
new house on it and the other property
be free and clear correct you know
that's a again I'll minor technicality
so but if the interest rates are the
same either way it really won't matter
much yeah right now the loan rate is at
three point five yeah and it's a fixed
rate yeah and you guys must be making a
ton of money because you're talking my
saving up another one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars really fast right well
my our main home is paid off so we would
sell that when we build the new home oh
and what's it worth um I'm hoping about
hundred twenty-five okay so that's the
other that's the balance correct uh okay
what's your household income ninety
thousand okay well neither one's stupid
uh and so it's not going to matter much
I don't care it does it really doesn't
matter I'm probably just going to leave
the loan in place that's there and build
it your new house for cash uh because
it's going to be just easier you're not
going to have any new loan expense
you're not gonna have to go through
appraisers and dealing with bankers you
have to get surveys on the lot you're
not gonna have to mess around with all
this other stuff dealing with a bank or
messing with your new building deal you
follow me yeah cuz you're paying cash
for that you can do whatever the flip
you want as long as it meets local codes
so it's just going to be simpler a
simpler life to do it that way either
way you're going to end up with around
100 a quarter hundred thirty thousand
dollars worth of debt on a house houses
that you want to get paid off with your
ninety thousand dollar income either way
right correct yeah so I'm just gonna
leave the one that's there there it's
simpler okay but there's there's no real
dumb dumb thing to do but it's just
that's my only reason for doing it okay
okay okay thank you so much for
information thank you for the call
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding so subscribe and there's
lots of videos about life and money so
while you're at it if you want to check
out a video then you can check out how
to do a monthly budget it's one of the
best videos out there
you